nous arrivons à la question
570 de Monsieur Daniel Laurent monsieur
le ministre de l'Agriculture de
l'agroalimentaire et de la forêt
oui monsieur le Président merci madame
la ministre mes chers collègues ma
question porte sur la mise en œuvre
d'une procédure de déclassement des
massifs boisés en forêt de protection
pour cause d'utilité publique ou pour
nécessiter absolue de travaux en
application des articles l411 1 L 413-1
r411 et r413,4 du code forestier peuvent
être classés en forêt de protection des
massifs boisés dont la conservation est
nécessaire à la lutte contre l'érosion
des sols pour des raisons écologiques ou
pour le bien-être de la population
or le déclassement d'une partie de forêt
de protection
nécessite la mise en oeuvre d'une
procédure longue complexe et à l'issue
favorable incertaine cette procédure
rarement utilisée doit respecter le
parallélisme des formes à savoir en
quête publique avis dû ou des conseils
municipaux concernés de la commission
départementale de la nature des sites et
des paysages et enfin transmission du
dossier au Conseil d'État qui entérinera
ou non par voie de décret la réduction
de la servitude ainsi dans le cadre d'un
simple projet d'urbanisme ou
d'infrastructure en limite de massif ou
sur des parcelles couvertes de quelques
arbres et friches sans enjeu
environnemental une procédure de 12 à 18
mois serait nécessaire pénalisant les
collectivités locales dans la conduite
de leur projet d'intérêt général
considérant que les études d'impact
diligentés par la direction régionale de
l'environnement et de l'aménagement du
logement la Dréal garantissent la prise
en compte de tous les risques et en jeu
environnementaux liés au projet des
collectivités
ne serait-il pas envisageable de
simplifier et d'harmoniser cette
procédure notamment par une
déconcentration au niveau des préfets de
région une déconcentration de la
décision du déclassement au niveau des
préfets de région
assureraient plus de souplesse tout en
garantissant la préservation des
objectifs fixés par la législateur en
conséquence
madame la ministre pouvez-vous me faire
part de vos observations sur cette
problématique et des propositions du
gouvernement à la matière qui rendrait
bien service aux collectivités merci
merci madame la ministre
monsieur le sénateur vous avez souhaité
interroger monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculteur de l'agriculture pardon
qui est retenue à une réunion sur les
quotas à Matignon le classement en forêt
de protection constitue actuellement
l'outil juridique le plus solide pour la
protection des forêts menacées la
procédure est centralisée le classement
comme forêt de protection étant prononcé
obligatoirement par décret en Conseil
d'État le projet est soumis à une
enquête publique dont le dossier doit
préciser préciser les motifs du
classement et la nature des suggestions
et interdictions susceptibles d'être
entraîné par le régime
forestier spécial
les effets principaux du classement sont
interdire le défrichement de soumettre
la gestion
forestière à des règles techniques
particulières de contrôler les droits
d'usage et de réglementer l'accès du
public cette procédure permet d'apporter
toute garantie tant qu'à la prise en
compte de l'expression de toutes les
parties prenantes que relativement à
l'intérêt du classement de chacune des
parcelles sous la surveillance du
Conseil d'État
toute modification est prise par décret
en Conseil d'État suivant donc la
procédure du classement je tiens à vous
préciser que la réglementation ne
prévoit pas de déclassement
ce statut étant par nature définitif
puisque l'objectif premier est justement
la conservation des forêts le classement
comme forêt de protection interdit tout
changement d'affectation où tout mode
d'occupation du sol de nature à
compromettre la conservation
ou la protection des boissements par
exemple en 1995 lorsque le ministre de
l'Industrie a sollicité une dérogation
pour permettre à la recherche
d'hydrocarbures en forêt de
Fontainebleau le Conseil d'État c'est
prononcé des favorablement en indiquant
que les puits de forage devaient être
établi hors du périmètre de protection
en créant le statut de forêt de
protection le législateur a voulu donner
une protection extrêmement forte à des
forêts dont la préservation présente un
intérêt exceptionnel cette procédure qui
ne couvre qu'une infime partie des
espaces forestiers nationaux doit pour
conserver tout son sens rester
strictement appliqué le Gouvernement
n'envisage pas de modification de cette
procédure
Monsieur Laurent
oui madame le ministre vous doutez bien
que cette réponse ne me satisfait pas du
tout et qu'elle n'est pas acceptable je
comprends bien que il faut apporter des
garanties pour la protection de nos
forêts et nous y sommes tous favorables
mais mon intervention était ciblée ça
veut dire que nous sommes tous quelque
part représentant des collectivités et
nous nous rendons compte que dans
certains cas précis les uns les autres
quand nous avons je l'ai cité tout à
l'heure des infrastructures ou des
routes ou des choses à faire passer nous
avons des fois à la marge besoin de
quelques mètres carrés je dis bien de
quelques mètres carrés parce que je l'ai
vécu en Charente-Maritime et je le vis
encore qui pourrait être dérogatoire
dans ces cas-là facilement pour pouvoir
faire des économies d'argent public
parce qu'on se rend compte qu'en
définitive cette conséquence nous
implique des acquisitions foncières
souvent onéreuses dans les bords de
côtes et littoraux et ce qui fait que
quelques mètres carrés quelques
centaines de mètres carrés qui ne
coûterait pas très cher qui permettrait
de passer nos infrastructures nous
ferait économiser beaucoup d'argent
public sur lesquels nous sommes obligés
d'investir pour acquérir d'autres mètres
carrés qui sont souvent constructibles
ou habitées donc voilà c'est un peu de
bon sens que je demande et c'est
simplement dans le cadre de ce bon sens
tout en préservant bien sûr les forêts
que nous avons qui sont très belles à un
moment que le gouvernement s'y penche et
réfléchissent sur cette possibilité qui
pourrait nous être offerte nous
représentants des collectivités merci
merci question 456 de Monsieur
Jean-Claude Péronnet à monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur
merci monsieur le Président
ma question était destinée au ministre
de l'Intérieur vous y répondrez madame